مساء الخير ليست كل ايام الله سواء هناك
ايام اكثر حميه من ايام في سنوات بتمر ولا
يذكرها كدا تاريخ واحد في المقابل في
سنوات بتكون حافله بالاحداث المهمه جدا
الاحداث اللي بتغير مكر التاريخ السنوات
اللي بتضمن عدد كبير قوي من لحظات التحول
كما يسميه المؤرخون مش كثيره في عمر
العالم كله بتلاقي انه فيه عدد معين من
السنوات دائما مؤثر في عمر شعوب معينه او
في عمر العالم كله
على مدار الزمان يعني زي مثلا سنه الف
وسته وستين بالنسبه لبريطانيا سنه
1848 اللي ش ثوره في فرنسا ضد السلطه اللي
موجوده ومنها انتقل الى خمسين دوله في
اوروبا كلها وبالمناسبه سمي هذا العام
بربيع الشعوب وهو ده الاسم اللي تم على
اساسه تسميه ما حدث في 2011 وما اعقبها
بالربيع العربي في
1917 الثوره البلشفيه الاساسيه لقيام
الاتحاد السوفياتي في سنه الف وتسعمائه
وخمسه واربعين نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وبناء النظام العالمي الجديد
لكن في شبه اجماع ما بين المؤرخين ان
العام ان العام
1979 هو العام اللي بيشكل القرن الواحد
والعشرين اللي احنا عايشين والان هو ما
بدا في الف وتسعمائه وتسعه وسبعين من
احداث يشكل حياتنا حتى هذه اللحظه وعايشين
يوم بيوم حصل ايه في سنه تسعه وسبعين حصلت
احداث كبيره لكن اهم اربعه غيروا العالم
ومنطقه الشرق الاوسط الى ما شاء الله
الحدث الاولاني بدا مع تسعه وسبعين كان
الثوره الاسلاميه في ايران وفي طبعا
الثوره الاسلاميه كانت نتيجه غضب واحتقان
من نظام الشاه موجود على مدار السنوات
وبدات في 77 78 لكن في يناير تسعه وسبعين
تحديدا في سطاشر تسعه وسبعين ادبرت
المظاهرات والثوره الشهر الى الرحيل لاجئا
الى مصر وفي 1 فبراير ليجي ايه الله
الخميني من ال من من فيه بعد 14 سنه من في
كان اخرها في فرنسا بينزل بطائرته الى
طهران ثم في 11 فبراير
الثوره او بيكتب للثوره النجاح في سقوط
اخر يعني
الاخر مجلس للحكم القديم وبالتالي يستتب
الامر الى الثوره لكن استتب الامر للثوره
داخليه لكن لم يستتب الاستقرار لا لايران
ولا الى العالم ولا الى المنطقه حول ايران
وقتها والى الان الثوره اعلنت خطاب لاعب
جدا
واستخدمت خطاب اقلق كل دول المنطقه و
تكلمت عن
دورها في نصره المستضعفين وبدات تتكلم على
الانظمه الخانعه واللي هي اه يعني
ادوات الشيطان الاكبر للولايات المتحده
واسرائيل وبالتالي
او اثارت قلق في دول المنطقه كلها وكان
احد اهم ما اسباب ال ال
صحيحه ثوره بتكلم على شيعه ولا سنه يعني
في خط بها على لسان الزعماء لكن كان في
خوف ان الثوره دين تنتقل على الاقل بشكل
مذهبي الى الدول المجاوره وده كان السبب
الرئيسي من ضمن اسباب اخرى اللي دافع صدام
حسين بمباركه من بعض دول المنطقه في انه
يغزو ايران مباشره في العام التالي خوفا
من ان الثوره تنتقل الى من ايران الى
العراق وبالتالي يصبح في تغيير في نظام
الحكم اه نتيجه لقيام الثوره وكانت
النتيجه حرب استمرت سنوات اتت على الاخضر
واليابس ضحاياها اكثر من مليون بين
الجانبين وبنتكلم على رقم قرا في وقتها
كانت التقديرات باكثر من اربعمائه مليار
دولار الدنيا كلها تغيرت بعض الحرمين ال
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه ونتيجه حتى بعد
انتهاء الحرب تاثير الثوره مازال قائم الى
الان كل الاحداث اللي احنا بتتكلم عليها
من العالم كله بيتكلم عليها هو احد توابع
وليس يعني الثوره الامين ليست هي السبب
الوحيد ولكن ها السبب رئيسي في كل
التغيرات اللي حدثت في اه المنطقه ولايران
حتى هذه اللحظه الحاليه سنه 2019 اللي
الامريكان يتحدوا ان في الذكرى الاربعين
للثوره سوف تكون اه ارسنال هذه ال هذا
النظام اللي هو نظام الملالي الايراني في
نفس السنه وفي اه مارس الفين و سنه الف
وتسعمائه وتسعه وسبعين حدث حدث اخر مهمه
جدا ما زال تاثير كبير علينا الحداده هو
توقيع بقيه السلام ما بين مصر اسرائيل في
فتره حكم الرئيس
انور الثلاث دوافع الرئيس انور السادات
ممكن ت تعمل في ارسال الدكتوره لكن في
النهايه حصلت المبادره الاول بالزياره
وزار تل ابيب في سنه سبعه وسبعين وبعدين
اه تتابعت الاحداث اه انتهاء الوصول الى
اتفاقيه سلام سنه التسعه والسبعين الاتفاق
قيادي كان لها تاثير يعني كبير جدا او لو
انه كان مقتل السادات كنتيجه للغضب اللي
اصاب بعض طوائف الشعب المصري انه السلام
حزم الى اتفاقيه سلام لم يستشر فيها الشعب
حتى وان كانت عنده بعض المنطق في اجراء ال
اتفاقيه النتيجه ان تولي الرئيس مبارك
الحكم في ذهن وما حدث السادات وعمليات
الاغتيال وفي يوم 6 اكتوبر من بعض الافراد
اللي كانوا يرتدون الزي العسكري الجيش
المصري بطل هاجس الامن عند الرئيس مبارك
وسيطر على نحو تسعه وعشرين سنه من الحكم
في انتهت فيها ان وحداشر على المستوى
الاقليمي وعلى المستوى الدولي تغيرت
العلاقه ما بين العرب واسرائيل الى الان
لانه مصر خرجت من ال معادله النتيجه انه
ال الجبهه العربيه تفككت والنتيجه انه
السوريه اللي كانت شريك في الحرب مع مصر
في سنه ثلاثه وسبعين وجدت نفسها معزوله و
وحيده
ورغبه منها في ان هي تواجه الضغوط
الاسرائيليه والامريكيه استعانت بدوله
اخرى كبيره معزوله نتيجه الثوره فيها اللي
هي ايران وبدات من سنه تسعه وسبعين
العلاقه الخاصه ما بين سوريا وايران هي
موجوده حتى الان واللي بتكلم على ان
العلاقه ما بين طهران ودمشق علاقه طائفيه
يجهل حقائق الامور
دولتين يعانوا من العزله ويعاني من ظروف
صعبه قرر ان مصالحهما ان تكون معا وكان
احد الاسباب قيام الثوره في تفاهم وتوقيع
اتفاقيه السلام في مصر واسرائيل
والحقيقه انه ترتب على هذه الاتفاقيه امور
اخرى كثيره منها انه اسرائيل قررت انها
تكفي لوحدها
الشعب الفلسطيني
وبدا باتفاقات اصول فشلت حتى الان وبعدين
ا ستفرض بالسوريين وكانت النتيجه اخر
توابع هذا الاستفراد هو الاعتراف الامريكي
لضم الجولان كلام 1019
الاردنيين ما كان لهم ان يوقعوا اتفاق
العرب او اتفاق سلام سنه اربعه وتسعين مع
الاسرائيليين ولان السادات وقع اتفاقيه
السلام مع الاسرائيلي سنه
الفين سنه 1979 انا هنا مش في معرض
الادانه ولا المدح انا بقول ان يترتب عليه
امور كثيره منها اننا نعيش اجواء الان اه
استقواء اسرائيل تماما نتيجه تشكك في
الجبهه العربيه نتيجه حروب مصر من
المعادله كون ان فيه اخرين لهم راي ايجابي
في الاتفاقيه وانها كانت الحدث من احداث
هيئه لم يكن نتيجه الاتفاق ولكن نتيجه عدم
ادراك العرب لوجهه نظر اه السادات وقت هذه
وجهه نظر لها كل الاحترام لكن هذا ليس
مكان الخلاف على القرار السبب حصل ايضا في
هذا العام حدث مهم جدا وهو وصول رئيس
الوزراء البريطانيه مارغريت تاتشر الى
السلطه في مايو سنه تسعه وسبعين الحركه
يبدو بنا في المنطقه حدث عادي وصل رئيس
الوزراء في بريطانيا ولا الرئيس في امريكا
ولا الرئيس في فرنسا صوت يعني المشكله
المشكله انها كانت مارغريت تاتشر فالعالم
قبل مارغريت تاتشر كان شيئا
بريطانيا قبل ما اجي تتشاركان شيئا وبعد
وصول ان السلطه اصبحت شيئا اخر تماما
البريطاني اللي اعرف فيه السلطه اثناشر
سنه عمل التغييرات كبيره جدا في بريطانيا
لكنها انعكست على العالم المتغير انهى كان
عنده ايمان كبير جدا جدا بانه يجب للدوله
ان يتراجع دورها في اداره شؤون البلاد
ويجب ان تمنح الحريه كامله للقطاع الخاص
واستعان
شخصيه امريكيه مهمه جدا اسمه فريدمان
تكلمنا عنه في حالات ما هي الليبراليه
الجديده وكيف غيرت العالم ارجو ان انت
وترك عون لها اه الاخ فرد من ده اقتصادي
امريكي يؤمن بما يسمى الليبراليه الجديده
اللي هي لايجاد شديد جدا والتفاصيل موجوده
في الحلقه اللي حضرتكم عليها بيؤمن بانه
لازم الدوله قدرها محدود جدا الحكومه
دورها محدود والافراد هما اهم شيء حريه
الافراد مقدم على على على الاقتصاد الدول
وان الدول تصبح قويه اذا اصبح الافراد و
احرارا كلام جيد لكن في التطبيق النهائي
النظام ده استمر منذ وصول اه مارغريت
تاتشر الى السلطه اخذ زخما كبيرا جدا بعد
ان تولى رونالد ريغان الرئاسه في امريكا
بعد حوالي عامين لكن بعدها تغير العالم
كله واصبحت الليبرالي الجديده النظام
الاقتصادي السائد في العالم الى يومنا هذا
واحنا النهار ده يعاني من مشاكل انه هذا
النظام اصبح يحمل الينا الكثير جدا من
الازمات
عدد محدود جدا من الافراد انه الحكومه
ضعيفه جدا في قدرتها على حل المشاكل نتيجه
انتقال الثقل الاقتصادي للشركات والى
الافراد كميه تكرار عدد الازمات الدوليه
في العالم كثيره واخرها سنه الفين وثمانيه
والعالم يستعد لاستقبال الازمات على جبهه
اخرى تغير الاقتصاد وتغير العالم بعد وصول
مارغريت تاتشر الى السلطه سنه تسعه وسبعين
قبل ان يغادر العام نهايته او قبل ان
ينتهي العام في ديسمبر الفين سنه تسعه
وسبعين حدث حدث مرابع مزلزل
الاتحاد السوفياتي الى افغانستان طبعا
السوفياتي ما بدوش زينه ولكن احنا تعينها
من قبل الحكومه الشرعيه
لمساعدتها عشان تتخيل الوضع وتاهل انها
قصه طويله زي الوضع في سوريا كانت هناك
معارضه
وهناك حاكم الحاكم الحكومه كانت حكومه
مواليه الاتحاد السوفياتي والمعارضه كانت
مدعومه مع من الامريكان والغرب طلبت
الحكومه تدخل الاتحاد السوفياتي دخل في 24
ديسمبر على ما اذكر سنه تسعه وسبعين لكن
تغير الاتحاد السوفياتي وتغيرت المنطقه
كلها لانه
بريطانيا والولايات المتحده وجدت ان دخول
الاتحاد السوفيتي افغانستان مثلا ستدخل
الى المصيده واصبح جاهزا للقضاء على
القضاء على باستنزافه تماما واخترعوا فكره
التشجيع الحركات الجهاديه وقتها
اللي عايش الفتره دى زى حالاتى كده حين
كنت طفلا كلنا بنقرا اليوم عن اه عن
بطولات الجهاديين والاسلاميين والجماعات
الزين ربنا ب يؤيد لهم الملائكه وكان
الامريكان والمخابرات الامريكيه بتنشر هذه
الافكار النتيجه انه بعد عشر سنوات
استنزاف الجيش السوفيتي العظيم فقط كثير
من كبار وتو من هيبته وفي العامل خرج منه
سقط حائط برلين سنه تسعه وثمانين وكانت
مقدمه ل انهيار الاتحاد السوفياتي كله
كانت احد نتائج هذا الحدث الكبير انه تبلغ
التنظيمات الجهاديه في العالم كله تنظيمات
كثيره مختلفه ما زلنا حتى الان من عشره
يعني الطالبان خرجت من رحم الغزو الامريكي
الغزو السوفياتي لافغانستان وظهور
الجماعات الجهاديه القاعده اللي اساسها
اسامه بن لادن خرجت من رحم هؤلاء
الجهاديين والقاعده هي اللي عامله حداشر
سبتمبر احداشر سبتمبر هي الغياره العالم
كله ادت مره اخرى الى انه الامريكاني
اضطروا الى دخول ال افغانستان في الفين
وواحد والى ضرب العراق ثم في الفين وثلاثه
ثم
الاستمرار في احتلال
لغايه 2011 و بقاء القوات الامريكيه حتى
هذه اللحظه كلها احداث وتتابع
الحقيقه انه كثير من الاحداث طبعا احنا
صراحه الانباء حتى الان الامريكان ب
يتفاوضوا مع طالبان والايرانيين يتفاوضوا
مع طالبان وطالبا ما زالت تحكم حتى الان
من طلبه جامعه خرجت زي ما قلت لحضرتك
نتيجه الغزو السوفياتي وتشجيع الامريكان
والسعوديين والمصريين وكل حلفاء امريكا
لهؤلاء الجهاديين اللي انقلبوا على العالم
لاحقا داعش والخلاف الاسلاميه المزعومه
خرجت من رحم القاعده وهي احد التطور او
اشكال الجماعات اللي نتجت عن ظهور القاعده
الحقيقه
سنه تسعه وسبعين وبحق العام اللي شكل
القرن الواحد وعشرين
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]